oui on fait le bis vers 17h vous
concevoir il avait dû père il ya un tout
petit peu de violence là mais il faut
bien préciser que c'est pas du tout
verger à wolf au contraire ce sont les
stars couple intelligent moderne qui
essaie de se comprendre et ce sont en
fait deux êtres blessés qui essaient de
se respecter mais qui bon la vie fait
mais je ne sais pas oui c'est ça si vous
vous laissez c'est l'histoire d'un
désenchantement c'est à dire que pierre
l'homme à l'homme en général si vous
voulez ce2 se contente d'un bonheur
tranquille alors que la femme a elle
besoin davantage de rêve et eon prendre
le couple au moment où cette crise
commence et anne personnages que sont
aplaties zabel et là simplement pour
réveiller le couple et et et provoquer
dans cette espèce d'endormissement
quelque chose qui va qui va faire en
sorte que leur vie soit mieux et
intervient à la suite d'un dialogue
inédit un moment qu'un homme ne comprend
jamais les reproches d'une femme vous
êtes d'accord avec ça isabelle oui c'est
ce qu'on dit souvent c'est vrai que la
femme rêve souvent dindane ailleurs et
que c'est très dur à l'aude pour l'homme
de comprendre exactement de quoi est
fait cet ailleurs mais dans le film à
l'essai de le lui dire c'est vrai que
cet homme qu'elle a rencontré c'est un
peu un prétexte d'ailleurs on le voit
jamais les personnages sont très
mystérieux existe on se demande même si
je pense parce qu'il existe mais
l'utilisent comme un prétexte pour lui
signaler que quelque chose ne va plus je
crois que là cette histoire c'est la
séparation de deux personnes qui
s'aiment mais probablement que bien
souvent dans les séparations les gens
s'aiment encore c'est pour ça que c'est
si douloureuses et difficiles
d'une certaine façon ils s'aiment encore
dans tous les couples citations célèbres
y en a toujours un qui s'ennuient et
l'autre qui souffre et réciproquement
dans le film celui qui s'ennuient c'est
plutôt vous isabelle est celui qui
souffre c'est plutôt vous donner est une
citation que le personnage d'isabelle
trouve sur les portes de toilettes dans
les cabinets donc si vous voulez ça ne
fait pas référence diama rivonia que
survint si c'est oui effectivement ou
ccg dire et je dirais qu'ils vont
souffrir chacun à leur tour c'est à dire
que c'est autant douloureux pour elle
que pour moi cette cette séparation ils
vont essayer ils vont tout faire pour ce
pour se préserver ils vont tout faire
pour se conduire intelligemment
ils vont tout faire pour préserver leurs
enfants mais au bout d'un moment si vous
voulez ce qui se passe malgré
l'intelligence c'est que la douleur rend
bête et l'enfant va très vite devenir un
instrument de 2,2 chantage malheureux
l'enfant loulou qui vendent au rabelais
qui est le propre fils du réalisateur
joué l'un wii qui s'amusent à être qu'il
s'amuse à filmer vous amuser à filmer à
la vidéo font pas me raconter tout le
film vous n'aviez jamais travaillé
ensemble sauf erreur sur un plateau de
cinéma et alors j'ai lu une interview
dit que vous aviez beaucoup rigolé et
que vous avez pris des fous rires sur ce
tournage heures quand on voit le film on
a peine à y croire mais c'est que c'est
un film grave grave mais avec des tas de
moments très très rythmé si vous voulez
avancer
en contrepoint en contrepoint de notre
couple qui veut se séparer il y à un
autre couple qui lui veut se marier et
ça crée des situations absolument vous
dire drôle voilà c'est pas parce que les
acteurs tourner des scènes dramatiques
tout risque c'est interdit de s'amuser
d'un mot daniel
triomphe est encore sur les écrans dans
votre tout à fait exceptionnel dans la
reine margot avoue isabelle dans
amateurs d'un mot rapidement parce que
nous sommes un petit peu pressés par le
temps comme d'habitude vos projets
cinématographiques à l'un et à l'autre
et bien tout c'est à dire que moi je
vais tourner un film avec claude chabrol
prochainement quatrième film s'appellera
la cérémonie et moi je vais tourner le
monde deuxième film avec un de tes chine
et qui s'appellera l'enfant la nuit avec
catherine deneuve
les gosses illégalement bravo mois-ci
donc sorti mercredi de ce film la
séparation après merci beaucoup appris